Le retour aux bases
Aux débuts de Pêcheur de Trésors
Avec la Pêcheur de Trésors mobile numéro 1
Toujours debout.
Salut à tous, c'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes de retour pour pêcher à l'aimant dans cette carrière abandonnée.
On a déjà trouvé un mauseur allemand ici, ainsi que pas mal de morceaux de véhicules découpés.
Voyons voir ce que l'endroit nous réserve.
Allez, là, j'ai quelque chose.
Si ça vient, hein.
Wow !
Attends, c'est quoi ça ?
On dirait pas un morceau de voiture.
Uh-huh !
Intéressant.
Ou alors, c'est un énorme poste.
C'est un lecteur...
Si vous savez ce que c'est en commentaire.
En tout cas, ouais, c'est un appareil électronique.
Si ça vient, ça vient.
Hey !
Oh, c'est un pot d'échappement
Ouais, regarde.
C'est un pot de voiture, ça, oui ?
Scooter.
Scooter ? Ouais.
Ok.
Ça commence bien, hein.
Ah ben, encore un morceau de voiture.
Ah, ils ont fait quelques petits bouts, quand même.
Ah, ça vient ?
Ouais.
Oula !
C'est massif, hein.
Ouais, c'est énorme.
T'as deux objets.
Un silencieux de pot d'échappement.
Et ce gros morceau-là.
Encore un pot d'échappement.
Ouais.
Waouh, c'est abusé, là, tous les pots.
C'est une mobylette aussi, ça, encore, non ?
Ouais.
Ah, mais c'est dingue.
Il y a toute la ligne, là.
Ah ouais, là, il y a toute la ligne, là.
Nickel !
Bien joué.
Alex, pour le garage, hein.
Allez, nickel.
Bon, là, en vrai, super dépollution de sortir ça de l'eau.
Ça n'a rien à faire dans l'eau.
Ah bah ouais.
Il doit être rempli de vase en plus
Ah, c'est abusé, c'est rempli.
Ah, là, c'est le tour de roue, ça.
Ok.
Oh !
C'est bien, ça.
Je ne l'avais pas, non plus, dans la collection, celui-là.
Oh !
Allez, là, ça vient.
Ah, j'ai quand même un truc aussi.
Ouais.
Ah oui tu as quelque chose, je pense.
Et encore.
Oulah !
Ah, les pédales !
Ça, c'est stylé.
Un pédalier ?
Ouais.
Ça, c'est cool.
Ils ont prit le temps de le démonter, quand même.
Ouais.
Pour se fabriquer un petit simulateur de conduite dans le garage.
Ok.
Original.
Ah, là, encore une munition
Ici, on en a fait quelques-unes.
Bien, ça...
C'est bon signe, ouais.
Ah, regarde, c'est un cadre de moto
Ah, justement, tu disais que t'en voulais un.
Oh, il est vieux, hein.
Ah, mais celui-là, ouais.
Bien joué.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Allez, ok.
Alors, alors.
Là, j'ai quelque chose.
C'est gros.
Oh ! Un pneu
Sans la jante.
C'est bon pour la dépollution.
Rasta ! Descend, descend, descend.
Elle est ou Laika ?
Rasta, viens là
Viens là.
Rasta, descend.
Bon, on ne vous a pas tenu au courant,
mais là, ça fait une demi-heure qu'on est sur quelque chose
Sur un gros poisson.
Un gros morceau, moi, je pense au moins aussi gros que l'autre
On a essayé avec le premier treuil,
ça suffisait pas.
On a sorti le treuil 6 tonnes.
Et les bras.
Et les bras d'Alex.
Regardez ces veines.
Bon, voilà, là, ça fait déjà plus d'une heure que l'on galère facilement
Mais, on commence à apercevoir
quelque chose qui ressemble à une voiture.
Forcément.
Alors, peut-être une voiture entière, pour une fois
Ca serait une première.
Mais si c'est le cas,
on en a pour la journée.
C'est quand même fou que la corde n'est pas lâchée.
Parce que là, on a bien tiré comme il faut
et la corde est bien abîmée.
Bon, est-ce que ce serait
notre première voiture, là ?
On dirait, hein.
Enfin !
Sans faire exprès
Comment ca sans faire exprès ?
On sait qu'il y en a ici
Elle a un petit toit on dirait que c'est une coupée
Ouais, le toit est petit.
C'est vraiment pas une grande.
Ah ouais, ok, ouais.
Ah ouais, elle la voit bien, hein.
Non, elle n'est pas du tout entière, les gars.
Ah ouais ?
Elle est coupée en deux.
Je crois.
Ouais.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Ils l'ont littéralement coupé en deux.
Ah sinon, elle ne serait pas venue si facilement
Bon, deuxième technique.
Maintenant, on va treuiller avec la voiture
La technique du mécano
Qu'est-ce qu'il fait là, lui ?
Hé, elle arrive.
Tu vas filmer la remontée.
Allez, je vais prendre ma GoPro.
On la voit bien, là.
Elle est bientôt dehors
Ben attends
Ah ouais, t'es au bout.
On va l'attacher cette voiture ?
On est au quel mois, là ?
On est au mois de juillet.
Non.
Juillet - 3 mois
On est en Mars
En vrai, je pense que je vais me mettre la tenue de plongée
Ah, tu fais ce que tu veux.
Mets toi à poiles, ça plaira aux abonnées
Il va se geler les couilles.
Les tenues sont là pour ça
Ah frérot, il faut la tenue
Ben oui.
C'est bien la première fois que je te voit te décourager comme ça.
Ah ouais, mais là...
Au mois de mars,
j'ai ma tenue de plongée d'été.
Allez.
Bon, je vais me geler.
On la voit plus, là.
On la voit plus trop, là,
avec l'ombre.
T'es dessus ? Monte dessus
C'est bon.
Fais gaffe de ne pas t'entailler quand même,
Au purée le toit est fragile quand même
il est fragile, hein.
Elle est glacée.
Ça va treuiller dur, là, les gars.
Bon, normalement,
maintenant,
elle devrait sortir de l'eau
si on tire à fond,
si nos calculs sont bons.
Et sinon,
Alex,
il va tirer avec la voiture.
Elle va sortir.
Une golf.
Au purée mon nœud
par contre,
il a pris cher.
Ah ouais ?
Ah, ça a la coupe des golfs,
quasi sûr.
Ouais.
Ça y est,
Il y a un petit bout qui sort.
Elle est en train de naître.
Alors,
est-ce qu'il y a un cadavre dedans ?
Il semblerait pas.
Ouais, je pense pas qu'on y arrive, les refs.
Ah si
Bien vu, Alex.
Elle est un peu boueuse, hein.
La, là, elle est posée, là.
Donc là,
on peut défaire le treuil
et l'attacher à la vectra.
Ouais, je pense qu'on peut attacher à la vectra.
Je pense que, ouais,
de toute façon, la vectra.
Vous avez François qui tient l'arbre
et la corde,
Quentin qui glandouille.
Et Alex qui bosse.
Comme d'hab.
C'est gaffe, Alex, il a pas le permis.
Pas le dire, ça.
Je suis en train de le passer, mon permis, d'accord ?
Alex, il a les deux chiens,
à l'arrière de la voiture.
Attends, on part tous en famille.
Vous êtes prêts pour ce qui va vous arriver, les petits ?
Attention il y a la première,
hein, tombe pas dans le fossé direct.
...
Euh...
Ah, il y a les rochers qui le retiennent, hein.
Tu peux essayer encore un peu,
en vrai, éloignez-vous.
Vas-y, essayez un peu.
Vas-y, attends.
Oh non, on n'a rien vu, on n'a rien vu.
Peut-être des projections de cailloux sur une 206.
Oh non !
Bon, les gars,
est-ce qu'on donne le permis à Alex ?
Ah oui.
Oui, là.
Ouais.
ça devrais faire partie des épreuves ça
Bon, ouais.
Il reste à la ceinture de sécurité ?
Monte à l'intérieur si tu veux je te tire
Non, là, c'est un peu dangereux, je pense.
Allez, on est obligés de lester l'Opel Vectra
J'ai un pilote, j'ai un copilote.
Attends, je tire sur la corde.
En réalité, c'est lui qui tire.
Il va vous montrer la force qu'il a.
Ah, il y a des chiens derrière.
Libérez
Rasta
Attends, je n'ai pas filmé la procédure de démarrage.
On va montrer ça
C'est comme voler une voiture.
Oh putain.
Je te jure, cette voiture...
Alors, t'as quoi ? La première ou la marche arrière, là ?
Les freins, là.
Sans déconner
J'ai l'impression de la voler, ta voiture.
Tiens, je te prête les clefs
Allez, bon courage.
Le problème, c'est qu'ils sont face au mur, là.
Oh purée les affaires
Vas-y, repasse en marche arrière, ça le fait.
Allez, où est la clim, putain ?
RIP, la clim.
Elle est bloquée là
Ah ouais, c'est vrai, on aurait dû faire ça, ouais.
Tiens les clefs
Ouais perds pas les clefs toi
Je pense que tu n'as pas le choix de réavancer
On essaie de la bloquer en tenant.
C'est parti.
En vrai, elle est assez légère comme ça.
Ouais...
Il est à plat le pneu
Ouais, mais c'est mieux pour la grippe.
Pas pour la grippe, c'est pour le grippe.
C'est vrai ?
Et oui
Ça ne m'arrange pas, ça.
Tu confonds les genres ?
Mais oui.
Ah, tu sais, il n'y a plus vraiment de distinctions de nos jours.
Ah non, elle a une mauvaise sens.
Allez, on revient.
C'est bon.
Bon, là, je suis obligé de monter dessus, là.
Fais gaffe elle n'est pas très neuve Quentin
Bon.
Il est pas bon le pilote ?
C'est bon, elle est sortie, bien joué.
Elle est sortie.
Tu fais gaffe de pas passer à travers surtout
Ah ouais, là.
Et là, il y avait le réservoir, c'est ça, ouais.
C'est ça ?
C'est le réservoir.
Golfe, du coup.
J'ai bien l'impression.
L'amortisseur, il ne veut pas venir, là ?
Qui a un téléphone ?
Il n'y a plus de plaques.
Il y a un problème, là.
Ce n'est pas normal, ça.
Pourquoi ça se lève comme ça ?
L'essieu est un peu passé à travers.
Et là, il faut que l'amortisseur soit là.
Et ouais, en la base, hein.
Franchement, c'est grave drôle
Pourquoi t'as piqué les visses ?
Est-ce que les portières, elles marchent encore ?
Oui, elles marchent.
Tu casses ton matériel.
Chaque fois Baptiste casse tout
Elles marchent.
Et bien voilà
Encore un merci à Maison de la Detection
Pour l'aimant Barbarian
Regardez ce qu'il a pu sortir,
parce que vraiment, c'est avec la corde de Maison de la Detection
qui en plus est abîmée.
Plus l'aimant
On a réussi à sortir un truc comme ça.
Donc, bon matos.
Il y a le lien en description.
Oui, très bon matos.
C'est vrai que...
C'est un promo pêcheur de trésor
qui vous offre moins 5% sur toute la boutique.
Elle est rayée un peu, par contre, hein.
Il faudra faire la poliche.
Un petit coup de poliche.
Je suis sûr que
On n'y verra plus rien.
Donc, là, on a un indice.
Germany Volkswagen.
Et là, regardez, on a commencé à redresser un peu la béquille.
Attention
Oui, mais écoutez, c'est la fin de cette vidéo à la carrière.
Vous voyez qu'il en reste encore énormément.
Dans cette vidéo, vous avez vu Alex
tirer énormément sur l'opel
et jouer avec l'embrayage.
Vous avez vu que c'est un très bon pilote,
mais aussi, vous avez vu qu'on ne respectait pas cette voiture.
C'est très simple, en fait.
C'est le dernier jour de la voiture.
Elle va partir en destruction cet après-midi.
C'est pour ça qu'on s'est permis ça.
Sinon, on respecte les véhicules.
Vous le voyez avec celui-là, par exemple.
Il va être restauré par François.
Bon boulot.
Bravo.
Et on se dit à très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo de Pêche à l'aimant